hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast engaging the patient in the
treatment journey I am Judy Aurora
collaborates and I'll be introducing
your speaker today after the speaker
presentation she'll be monier director
of education for the melanoma Research
Foundation will moderate the
question-and-answer session we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can't submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on a green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Timothy turnham PhD Tim
turnham became the executive director of
the melanoma Research Foundation mrf in
January 2009 Tim shares the MRFs
commitment to supporting medical
research to find more effective
treatments and eventually a cure for
melanoma and he brings more than 30
years of experience in management
fundraising communication teaching and
research prior to joining the MRF Tim
served as chief executive officer of the
colon cancer alliance as well as
director of development for United
Cerebral Palsy associations he has also
served as the director of development
for the whitman-walker clinic and as
director of development at the
Children's Research Institute Tim holds
a BA in microbiology from the University
of Tennessee a master of divinity from
the New Orleans Baptist Theological
Seminary in a PhD from the Southern
Baptist Theological Seminary and now
turn it over to Tim Rice presentation
you
first of all thank you for being part of
this session of the training engaging
the patient in the treatment journey and
oh this is a bit different from the
other sessions which are more medically
oriented but there's a lot of medical
aspects to this as well so what would we
talk about is the importance of the role
of the patient and the treatment journey
the role of the patient and looking at
treatment decisions in communicating
with the healthcare team and how that
can impact outcomes so the melanoma
Research Foundation has a number of
programs that are designed for patients
and the underlying principle of these
programs is that patients who are well
supported and well-informed live longer
and better and this is the core belief
around which we build the programs that
are patient centric patients that are
well informed and well supported live
longer and better and we have a growing
body of data that reflects this I'm
going to pull up one brief quote here
that was done in a global analysis of
multi trial data looking at quality of
life and symptoms as prognostic factors
for survival and a number of different
tumor sites and from this article they
did a 2014 the current results
demonstrated that for each cancer site
at least one health-related
quality-of-life domain provided
prognostic information that was additive
over and above clinical and socio
demographic variables so the hrqol looks
at physical domain emotional domain
mental domain social domain and in every
cancer type at least one and often more
than one of those different aspects
provided prognostic information that
went beyond what you might anticipate
from a clinical perspective in other
words patients who are reporting higher
quality of life have better outcomes
some people have questioned quality of
life studies even though I think
increasingly they're being accepted as a
Norman a standard but people said well
okay quality of life is subjective what
is the value of self-reported quality of
life indicators we need a more objective
standard and yet I would argue that
quality of life isn't that subjective
and varies from patient to patient and
US healthcare providers see this all the
time I was struck by having met two
patients in fairly short order who were
both stage for patients and one of them
decided not to have any treatment done
whatsoever and the other one decided
they wanted to try everything
conceivable everything possible and over
the course of their treatment went to
three or four different treatment
centers they would work with one
healthcare delivery team who would say
look there's nothing else we can try
nothing is working and and that person's
response was that's not good enough on
going somewhere else so what was the
difference between those two patients
the first patient who wanted nothing
done was an 80 year old man who lived in
his cabin in the mountains and rural
North Carolina he'd had a great life he
had good family and he said you know
what I'm 80 years old I don't want to
spend a few months or a couple of years
in the hospital with an IV hooked up to
my arm I just want to sit in my cabin
and enjoy what few weeks I have left and
that for him was a quality of life
knowing that his cancer was taking his
life away knowing he had a very short
period of time to live but knowing that
he could spend that short period of time
in his own home surrounded by the
mountains that he loved was quality of
life for him the other patient was a
woman in her 30s who had just given
birth to her first child and she
literally would walk through fire to
have another week or two or three with
that baby she wanted her daughter to
grow up to remember her and so she did
everything conceivable and even beyond
what most medical care providers would
have suggested the cause for her quality
of life translated strictly
and the length of life she was willing
to go through pain inconvenience all
kinds of difficult situations because
quality of life with length of life for
her and I think this shows the quality
of life is subjective now having said
that we're seeing also a growing body of
data that quality of life and patient
well-being translates into basic biology
as well so another quote this is a study
that was published in 2010 says there is
a growing evidence from in vitro in vivo
and clinical studies that stress related
processes can impact pathways implicated
in cancer progression including
immunoregulation angiogenesis and
invasion contributions of systemic
factors such as stress hormones to the
crosstalk between tumor and stromal
cells appears to be critical in
modulating downstream signaling pathways
with important implications for
progression in other words this study
showed that stress hormones which are
immeasurable a piece of data actually
empathy ology around the tumor and
increased stress hormones can help
tumors escape the micro environment by
increasing this cross talk between the
tumor and the stromal cells so now we're
beginning to see that a psycho social
aspect air of rapacious reality
translates down into basic biology of
tumor progression and just one more
example of this Carlson and others and
2015 published of paper in cancer in
which they looked at the length of
telomeres and what they found which I
found quite striking is that
psychosocial interventions provided
stress reduction and emotional support
that resulted in trends toward telomere
length maintenance distress bit breast
cancer survivors compared with decreases
in usual care
in other words they could actually look
at the length of the pamirs and patients
who had breast cancer and compared those
who had stress reduction interventions
emotional support versus those who did
not have those interventions who did not
have that emotional support and they
found a tangible measurable difference
in the length of telomeres the ability
to maintain the telomere length between
those two subsets of patients clearly a
lot more work needs to be done but we
are seeing I think an overwhelming trend
toward both in the psychological
analysis and now in a physiological
analysis suggesting that patient
well-being is an important part of their
health outcomes and we believe that
important part of that patient
well-being is their engagement in the
treatment process so moving on a little
bit I would add that communication is
particularly important right now in the
melanoma space since 2011 six new drugs
have been approved for creating advanced
melanoma and we see more and more drugs
and drug combinations that are in the
queue we anticipate a lot of activity
over the next couple of years so that
will have even more options and and the
treatment landscape in some ways may
become even more complicated with the
influx of these six new drugs after more
than 13 years where nothing was approved
with the the the influx of these six new
drugs we have a lot of questions that
have not really been determined which
drugs which patients should receive and
what order should they receive these
drugs which drugs to given what
combination and all of this still is
more of an art than a science it's more
of a gut feel and you talk to people who
see a lot of melanoma patients and and
and ask them ok which drug do you give
first and they said you know it depends
sit down with the patient I look at the
whole picture I talked with the patient
and at the end of the day you kind of go
with what I feel like it's best and that
comes into the art of health care I
think
but it is highlights the fact that
communication with patients now are
particularly important for example the
targeted therapy drugs the zelboraf tap
and lure the mechanist tend to respond
very quickly a patient who is
insignificant amount of pain a patient
who has is concerned about rapid tumor
growth a patient who is had their
lifestyle impacted by the presence of
their tumor may want to go on a targeted
therapy a drug because number one the
response rates are high and number two
the response tends to be very fast and
so people can have fairly quick relief
from pain fairly fast return to normal
function on these targeted therapy drugs
however these drugs only work on average
in the median for about a year and and
that's a factor for other people who
might say I'd rather take my chances on
something that has the opportunity of
really curing me and having a long-term
impact another factor is how long a
patient needs to keep taking this drug
of all of these drugs your voice is the
only one that is given in a restricted
regimen so that the approved regimen for
your boy rick aluminum is for infusions
over three months and then you're done
and for some patients the idea that they
could try a regimen a protocol that
would take three months may be
challenging to get through but that they
can go through it over a period of three
months and possibly be done with their
melanoma experience can be very
attractive all of the other drugs as of
right now patients continue to take
until they no longer respond to those
drugs some people don't want to be tied
to that level of care particularly when
the drugs are infusion drugs and they
have to come back into an infusion
center over and over and over again it's
a major change in a major impact in
lifestyle and even a drug that's not one
of the nukes one of the older drugs that
the protocol of interleukin-2 il-2
some people may choose that for exactly
the same reason you go through the
procedure or you go through the protocol
and then you're largely finished with it
so this idea of communicating all of
these multiple pieces becomes
increasingly important in a crowded
landscape where the different drugs have
different benefits different challenges
different toxicities different average
response times different implications
for how the drug is taken and again
having the communication with the
patient engaging them in this decision
making helping them understand why the
drug is being given versus other drugs
will increase compliance and help the
patients make it through the protocol
more successfully so the next next thing
that consider about the world right now
is toxicity we're seeing major issues
with different kinds of toxicity than
had been seen before new types of
dealing with these kinds of drugs and
you see on this slide some of the kinds
of examples that we see particularly
with the immunotherapy drugs these are
all immunotherapy related toxicities
pneumonitis hepatitis colitis all of
these kinds of things and the unique
side effect profile and management
strategies of these kinds of drugs make
communication with patients essential
give an example of this when if you luma
mal was knew everyone and in the field
working on this drug knew that one of
the common toxicities is colitis and
with severe colitis the answer was not
to be found an anti dryer real drugs but
actually to be found in steroid
treatment and one patient who was on the
drug went on vacation and was several
hundred miles away from her oncologist
and developed severe diarrhea severe
colitis
while on vacation presented to the
emergency room told the doctor in the
emergency room you know here's the
problem that I'm having I'm a cancer
patient I'm on this drug and and the
emergency room doctor said on I know
what diarrhea looks like in cancer
patients right because because he was
accustomed to seeing chemotherapy
induced diarrhea and any prescribed
standard anti-diarrheal medical
medicines well this patient was actually
very aware of the toxicity profile if it
be looma mab and she said to him you
know this is not your standard
chemotherapy drug it's a different kind
of drug and and the doctor says yeah
yeah yeah I get it but I know how to
treat this and she said no but I think
it needs to be treated a different way
because this is an immunotherapy drug
and you don't need anti diarrheal you
need you need steroids and and doctor
said no you look I know what I'm doing
here I see this all the time and she
said look at least call my oncologist
and and so the ER doctor agreed and and
ended up speaking to the oncologists of
course put her on a regimen of steroids
and her colitis was resolved very
quickly and she was able to continue
with their vacation at the point though
is that very few patients would have the
ability emotionally I think in mentally
in that setting to push back against a
physician who's saying here's the best
course of treatment for you and and yet
had had she not pushed back in this case
she would have been treated with Santa
standard anti-diarrheal drugs which
would have had little likelihood
resolving her colitis and could have was
a result resulted in a much more severe
case of colitis and possibly even
perforated colon and any number of other
things so it's important for patients to
report toxicities and talk about
toxicities back with the doctor but
there's some challenges to that as well
so some patients don't want to be a
whiner they they want to complain to
their doctor they respect their
treatment team they like their nurses
they like their physicians that they
they don't want to be a bother that
don't want to seem like they're
complaining all the time and and so
they're reluctant to report these things
i think more significantly there's this
genuine fear if i tell my doctor that
i'm having problems she might take me
off of this drug that could save my life
and in the cancer space this is a real
tangible fear and I have known any
number of patients who have lied to
their treatment team about side effects
because they felt if they were honest
and forthcoming they would no longer
receive the therapy that would fight and
beat their cancer this is a major major
issue for patients there's a lot of fear
with this and and then also look it's
not that bad i can kind of suck it up
and get through it just kind of a man up
and and make it through all of this
thing this is part of what it means to
be cancer and this is exacerbated i
think a lot of the pictures we see of
cancer patients who look frankly and a
lot of the movies and the pictures who
look quite sickly and so people expect
to be sick when they're on a treatment
for cancer the fact is though in these
days for patients to make it through the
newer therapies in particular to the
amino therapies and to be able to stay
on drug the best thing for them to do is
to have good clear communication with
their treatment team and so this second
point about if i tell my doctor i'm
having problems she might take me off
the drug is exactly the opposite of the
reality the fact is the best chance that
people have of making through the drug
regimen and being successful with that
drug is to be in close and clear
communication with their treatment team
but this is a challenge and it's a major
difficulty for patients to know how to
talk to their doctors and and to be
encouraged to talk to their doctors
about this and then just one more brief
point either doing all of this has some
inherent difficulties so now we've seen
that quality of life is important it's
important from a psychosocial
perspective but it's also important from
a theological perspective we've seen
that patients who are are well supported
and well cared for word actually do
better they live longer and they live
better and we've seen why in the
melanoma space particularly good
communication between patients and
between the healthcare treatment team is
critical at this juncture so why doesn't
it happen better why isn't this a just
kind of a given and part of it is is a
culture in the health care delivery
system and here's a report from 2012
that looked at at the assumption that
doctors know best and and says the habit
of assuming the doctor knows best has
created a system where huge numbers of
patients aren't getting the treatment
they would have chosen if they were
fully informed now we know that this
idea the image that's here by this
little cartoon which was fairly common
in the 50s and the 60s and in fact it
was it was in part of kind of popular
media we heard it on television shows
and we heard it in movies and things
like that but the healthcare field has
changed and it's changing I think fairly
quickly and we're beginning to see a
more collaborative environment having
said that we still aren't where we need
to be and I recall sitting down for
breakfast cells at a medical meeting and
sitting down for breakfast with the
oncologist and and when he learned that
I worked with the patient advocacy group
he said and I hate it when people who
are my patients deal with groups like
yours because they always come in with
these ideas of how I should be treated
that idea they want to have an input
about their treatment he said I I went
to medical school I went through a
residency I've been doing this for years
I know what needs to be done here and
the patient just needs to trust me and
do what I say they should do this is
still the mindset I don't know very many
doctors who would be that vocal or clear
about it but I think it's still the
mindset that is part of the culture of
the health care delivery system unless
intentional steps have been made to
break through that culture and
it's almost a part of humor you can see
this little cartoon doctor I want to
choose how I'm treated and the doctors
responses you're not just ill you're
deluded and yet increasingly what we're
seeing is patients who do want to choose
how they're treated who do want to say
and their treatment protocol and again
this is challenging because a lot of
times the things that the patients come
up with or are not valid they're not
scientifically supported there's no data
supporting it they've read something on
the internet and and and and it sounds
almost ridiculous to the health care
treatment team and yet in order to
communicate to keep the lines of
communication open there has to be some
listening that happens there even even
listening to the silly things are other
challenges it was time so you as as
physicians and people who are health
care providers have seen this you know
the patient who comes in with a huge
stack of printing out saying you know I
went on Google and why aren't you
putting me in touch with this guy in and
this other country whose curing people
having them drink distilled goat urine
or rubbing magic rocks together and and
and mixed into this huge stack of papers
there may be some legitimate scientific
papers and there may even being some
things that that the team's not familiar
with but but there's going to be a lot
of garbage and you have 10 minutes to
sit down with this patient for your
entire lauded time for that appointment
and and you quite frankly don't have
time to go through 300 pages worth of
articles and to explain why node okay
this article was was refuted by later
data or you know this was published but
it was published in a publication that
was not a legitimate publication or yes
this is a study but it doesn't apply to
you because of these biomarkers and and
if you take all of your time about that
you don't have the time to communicate
other aspects of care and other aspects
of treatment that that could be really
important and
and more relevant to the well-being and
the care of the patient so so now I've
talked about the importance of
communicating with patients and and the
challenges of communicating with
patients so then i would like to think a
little bit about some solutions how do
we engage patients and the treatment
journey and how do we do that in a way
that really works for everybody and I
have some very specific suggestions for
this one is tell your patients what to
expect the fact is trading stage for
melanoma these days and probably any
stage four cancer is likely to be a
series of different treatments and a
patient should know this from the
beginning it is true that we will all
see those patients who will take the
first therapy that's offered and have an
amazing response and their cancer will
go away and never come back again and we
hear these stories and they're wonderful
stories to hear but we also know that
that's that's the exception rather than
the rule and all likelihood patient will
have some response to the therapy it
will last for a while but maybe not all
the tumors will respond or maybe the
tumors then we'll start growing back
issues of tumor heterogeneity will come
into play building resistance to the
therapy will come into play and the
health care provider team knows this
from the beginning the patients aren't
often informed of this from a patient
perspective when they're diagnosed with
cancer the first thing they think is am
I going to die and and when they sit
down with an oncologist and say what are
we going to do doctor their real
question is how are you going to keep me
alive and so then the doctor will say to
that patient well there's this drug
we're going to put you on this drug and
here's what it is and here what it's
going to be like and
and here's why are you put in we're
putting on this and for the patient what
they're hearing is this drug is it has
to work if I'm going to beat this cancer
and so if they go on a Purton a certain
regimen or a certain treatment protocol
and then the scans come back and the
tumors have grown or maybe half the
tumors have shrunk but the other half
have not the immediate thing they heard
is this drug as a failure I'm going to
die that can be mitigated by saying from
the very beginning look this is a series
of many steps not just one step and if
you're really lucky the first step will
take care of it it'll be one big giant
step your cancer will go away and you'll
be fine if you're really lucky lucky but
that's not likely to be the case we're
going to do this thing it'll probably
help you it'll probably help you to some
extent it may make all of your cancer go
away but it may not but if it doesn't we
have other things that we can try I
remember talking with one melanoma
expert who said that when when a patient
comes in to him for the first time
having been diagnosed with stage four
melanoma he will take the piece of the
paper you know that rolled out paper
that you put on the on the beds when the
patients come in and sit in the
treatment room he'll take a big long
roll of that paper and lay it out on
table with the patient and says look
here at the beginning we have four or
five different drugs that we could look
at that for you and and I'm going to
recommend that we do this one and here's
why and and I think it's going to work
for you but it may not and if it doesn't
the next step is we're going to go to
this drug and here's why I would use
that one second and then the third drug
will try if we need to will be this one
and then if that one doesn't work we'll
have other things we can talk about but
we'll talk about that later and then he
puts the patient on that first drug and
and hopefully the patient responds but
if they don't he brings them back
and say look I've got your scans back
your tumors aren't responding to the
drug we think it's try to think that
time to try something else and he'll
pull that sheet of paper back out and
say remember we said that this might
happen and that we said then that the
next step would be to try this drug so
that's what we're going to do and and
then you go on that drug and if that
drug doesn't work he'll pull that paper
back out again and he said you know
remember we said this might happen and
we would go this drug in this drug and
and we said the third drug we would try
would be this one but you know since we
started this thing you know the number
of months have passed by now and since
we started this a few things to change
and and now there's this available or
there's new data about this combination
and so instead of doing one we planned
on I'm going to recommend we do this
other one so the patients can hear from
the beginning that there is a plan that
involves not just one approach but
several sequential approaches and and I
think communicating this to patients
helps them manage their expectations to
say look cancer is tricky cancer has a
lot of different ways of escaping drugs
but we all have more and more drugs
available to track this thing down the
first one may not do it but that doesn't
mean it's the end of the story and and
and what we're looking for is giving you
hopefully a cure but if not a cure
keeping the cancer at bay and in the
fact there's you know patients and we
know patients who have had tumors kind
of sitting there rather indolent for
sometimes years and it's basically kept
in check patients who are new to this
journey don't know that telling them
from the beginning what to expect can
make a big difference so another thing
is make sure you have very clear
communication channels and I think this
is sometimes a challenge because when
when you talk to a patient and say I'm
sorry to tell you you have you have
cancer and you go on and say all the
different things you want to say to that
patient the fact is the patient never
hears anything beyond you have cancer
and and when we're chroma tized and when
we're afraid we cannot receive
information very well in fact that's the
time when we receive information the
very worse I recall some years ago a man
named Charlie who's an elderly man at
the time and and his wife was quite ill
she had been ill off and on for a number
of years but but it was really coming to
a head and and she was hospitalized and
and was not expected to make it through
this hospitalization and he called me in
the night as close to midnight and said
I'm at the hospital my wife Margaret is
not doing well and they don't expect her
to make it much longer could you come
down and sit with me which I did and we
SAT there by her hospital bed and we
talked about her life and how they met
and how they were married in the years
that they had spent together and and and
just had a great conversation and how he
said you know I know she's had a hard
time these last few years and and she
doesn't want to live like this and I
know it's for the best but it's really
hard and and and she began to have
difficulty breathing and went into chain
strokes breathing and as we have all
seen and and ultimately she just stopped
breathing and and I said Charlie I think
she's gone and and we should call the
nurse and and get the doctor in here and
get out everything verified and and so I
went down the call the nurse to come
into the room and to notify the doctor
and and Charlie says well what are they
going to do when I said what do you mean
he said well well what's the next step
in treating her you know what are they
going to do for her what how they gonna
how they gonna help her he was so
traumatized by the fact that his wife of
these many years had died that even
though he fully expected her to die he
didn't recognize that she had stopped
breathing and she in fact had not died
that's a very stark example
something that that is happening every
day with cancer patients and in terms of
how they can and cannot hear
communication so whether it's I'm sorry
to tell you you have cancer or whether
it's we got your scans back and the drug
your own is not working patients get
stuck at that point and have difficulty
hearing much more so one of the
solutions this are good systems and
understanding that reality and dealing
with it for in a systematic way so one
question is do you have clear systems by
which patients can easily report
toxicities it might arise and and the
time to talk about this may not be when
you tell a patient they've just had
cancer when do you communicate to the
patient how do you communicate that to
the patient is it something in writing
the patient's no do all of your patients
know when and how to talk about the side
effects that they're experiencing and
and my guess is that from the healthcare
provider perspective it seems very clear
but from the patient perspective I can
tell you it often feels very arcane when
do I when do I raise this to that level
when do I ask that question when do I
talk to the doctor what am I being a
whiner and complaining all the time and
when is there something I generally need
the report systems can help make that
clearer and make that path easier for
patients do you address toxicity
throughout the course of treatment you
know obviously when when you put your
patient on a new drug you sit down and
say here's the drug here are the kinds
of side effects that people have and
here's what we can do about it but but
they're going to be on that drug for a
while hopefully and and hopefully for a
long one and this that needs to be part
of the conversation routinely not just
at the beginning to say okay look we're
seeing some benefit from this we're
seeing good things happen remember that
we talked about toxicities and you might
experience some of these things are you
experiencing one of those things do we
need to talk about this remind them of
the importance of that communication
again having that built into the regular
discussion that you have can be very
important and then to go back to my
other earlier point
if your patient had an issue while away
on vacation during a holiday weekend
would they know what to do would they
know how to have their side effects
managed properly in that kind of setting
because from the patient perspective it
seems that things things always happen
after hours and on the weekends and it
always happened when you're on vacation
and so will they will they know how to
respond where they know how to
communicate is there a clear again a
clear system for communicating the
things that the patients are
experiencing so having clear
communication channels that are
reiterated and hopefully pass along not
only the patient but there's significant
other who is helping them manage this
can make those lines of communications a
lot simpler so another way to help find
solution is to pay patients with other
patients and i put here a screenshot of
a bulletin board that the melanoma
Research Foundation has called MP IP it
stands for melanoma patient information
pages it actually predates our
organization it goes back over 20 years
now and it is a very active vibrant
thriving online community and you can
see from this the kinds of things that
could get pushed up there you know what
how do I deal with the side effects of
interferon hey here's a report I read
about that it talks about combining
drugs another person saying look I and
what excited fex of people experience
being on katroo de somebody else in well
can you can combine contribu with
alternative therapies and and here's a
question about a stage 3 patient and
these are the kinds of things that
happen and and what we see routinely in
here is that patients are looking for
answers to things like what does it mean
that my doctor tells me to go on this
drug and why this drug and not other
drug or how do I deal with the side
effect that I'm experiencing from this
drug patients will talk to each other in
ways that they will not talk to the
healthcare provider and this has some
risk to it but it has a lot of benefit
to it as well
sometimes patients understand that real
world experience and they can share that
information with each other what I've
seen over and over again on this
bulletin board through the years is a
patient saying I'm on this drug I'm
having this issue and other patients
will say you need to talk to your doctor
right now about this so that question if
you're on the fence if you're on the
bubble I don't want to be complaining I
don't want to bother the doctor it's
just a Saturday night at eight o'clock I
don't I don't want to be a pest to
anybody and and deep inside the patient
knows I need to make the call but
they're just afraid to do it they can
get into a situation like that and hear
from other people saying yet you need to
make the call you need to move forward
you need to ask the question and and and
they can get then the kind of
communication that they need to have
with the team to ensure that they're
able to stay on protocol and to stay in
the drug so it's not only through our
bulletin board there are a lot of
Facebook groups there are people now on
Instagram we're seeing even patients in
using Twitter to talk about toxicities
which I don't even begin to understand
how you can do that in 140 characters or
less but it's happening and and this is
the evolving in the new world that we're
in if you don't have somebody from your
health care team who is active in social
media you may be missing out on a lot of
conversation that your patients are
having with each other and with other
patients and then of course support
group support groups have been around
for a long long time they can be
challenging but they can also be
tremendous opportunities for people to
learn and to grow and to connect with
other people so again there are ways for
you to help patients get the support
that they need to live longer and better
by connecting to other patients we
launched a program at the melanoma
Research Foundation a couple of years
ago that we call a phone buddy program
and we have people who have been down
the treatment pathway some length of
time and they are trained and taught
how to speak to other patients and then
partnered up with somebody who is newly
diagnosed or somebody who's newly
dealing with the recurrence or somebody
who's on a new treatment for the first
time so we have people who've gone
through aisle to who we pair up with
somebody who's considering aisle two we
have people who've gone through the
targeted therapies or the
immunotherapies who can be partner
definitely who's being told by the
doctor we want to put you on this drug
so they can help them walk through that
journey and having that person who's
been where they have been who has been
through what there have been there going
through can make a tremendous difference
in helping the patient know that they
aren't alone that other people have gone
through some of these things and that
they can make it through as well so I
guess one last point here and then we'll
have some time for questions is is that
always remember patients are people too
and I know that everybody who's watching
this and listening this knows this but
also know that we all get very very busy
and we get busy with our routines and we
get busy with the things we have to get
done and and sometimes we can lose sight
of the humanity of the people that that
we're putting in which is really why
everybody's in the health care field
anyway so how do we balance this out you
know you you are not their friend but
you can be warm and friendly and a smile
on the face a friendly word can open the
door to communication that otherwise
would not have been possible you're not
their therapist but you can be sensitive
and understanding and look for cues that
a patient is struggling and refer them
to therapy if they need to be referred
to therapy refer them to somebody who
can help take care of their emotional
needs and we've all seen these patients
who like look like they walk in and they
just look like they're utterly utterly
lost and completely bereft of hope
somebody needs to intervene and and to
help get them back on track because hope
is the thing that will help them make it
through the treatment that
the best chance of taking care of their
cancer you're not there minister but you
can and you should listen and care and
so I think this balance of being warm
transparent and open while still
maintaining the very important
professional boundaries sets the tone
since the culture sets an environment
but which patients can understand here's
somebody that I really can't talk to and
I don't have to be afraid of that I went
to a cancer center two years ago I
suppose and it was in a high-rise
building and when I walked into the
lobby and went over to the elevators and
he pushed that button and the elevator
opens up and there in the corner of the
elevator was a padded stool and I knew
immediately why that stool is there
though I've never seen it anywhere else
the fact is that cancer patients often
or weak they're feeling nauseated their
child just walking in the door may have
been the hardest thing they had done
that day and here in the elevator was a
place where they could sit down for
those few seconds that it took to get
from the first floor to the eighth floor
and and those few seconds of being able
to sit down might really help and I
don't know if anybody ever used that
stool but the fact that it was there
said something about that institution
about that location you get into the
waiting room there up on that that floor
and in the waiting room is a little
basket with crackers and they're just
free for anybody who takes it and we all
know the cancer patients struggle with
nausea sometimes and sometimes just a
plain saltine cracker can help with that
so setting the culture setting the tone
where patients know that they are valued
that they are seen as people can open
the door for communications and in ways
that are really really important and
just one final humorous thing it's a
little cartoon and and the doctor saying
I didn't ask you to undress so I could
examine you
ask you to undress because it's central
to the doctor-patient relationship that
I be fully clothed and you be sitting
there and your underwear so okay we know
that's not really the attitude sometimes
it may feel like that and I can tell you
having a serious conversation about
toxicities psychosocial well-being is
kind of challenging when you're sitting
in a cold room with nothing on with your
skivvies or one of those silly little
hospital gowns and the doctor standing
there with their coat and tie on again
structure culture environment can make a
big difference bottom line is let's
engage our patients and and the
treatment journey and I guarantee you
the patients who are engaged in that
level will in aggregate at least live
longer and better thank you for your
time and we have a few minutes for
questions if we have any thank you Sam
that was fantastic we have several
minutes for questions so please submit
those and we can answer those for you
first i'd like to point out that we you
know this presentation has everything to
do is patient doctor communication but
if you have any thoughts on doctor to
doctor communication perhaps for those
folks who don't live near say
specialists who know a lot about
melanoma or a specific melanoma
treatment team do you know our our
melanoma specialists often willing to
work with local oncologist so that the
patients don't have to travel so so how
do the how do the oncologists
communicate with one another do you have
any comments or or thoughts around that
yeah I think this is a great point
because the fact is a lot of oncologists
will only see a couple of melanoma
patients a year and it's hard to stay
current with everything that's going on
and what I found is the melanoma space
is has historically been highly
collaborative there's one very senior
expert in the melanoma field I talked to
about this at one point and and he told
me I'll always remember this he said you
know
and in the melanoma space you can't
afford to be here again because this is
a cancer that is humbled us all and so
they tend to be highly collaborative and
I know most of the melanoma experts I
know are very interested in
collaborating with community oncologists
around care and and what that typically
means is they do want to see the patient
one time look over the files look at
everything then then work with the local
oncologist to come up with a treatment
protocol and then make themselves
available if there's some things that
arise like a haven a patient is having
this issue what do you do about that but
they're they're very interested in
having the patient treated locally and I
know patients who are going through
exactly that situation right now thank
you and next question a flash comment I
know that researchers are currently
looking at which order to give patients
which drugs do we have any results of
those studies yet or is it was it still
too early to know if it's best to give
an immunotherapy before a targeted
therapy or a targeted therapy first and
then an immunotherapy or is it too early
to have those results this just data
that's still being developed and still
being mature there's a couple of studies
that are just starting looking
specifically at that question with
targeted therapy and immunotherapy and
part of the problem is the targeted
therapy field has evolved and the
immunotherapy field has evolved even
more quickly so had you done this study
three years ago you wouldn't have had
the two newest drugs anti pd-1 drugs
that are showing so much more epica see
an anti ctla-4 drug if you loo a map so
you have to do it all over again don't
really know i think that the general
feeling is that people are tending more
toward immunotherapy now because of the
potential for long lasting benefits the
pd-1 drugs tend to be a little bit
faster and responsive in responding than
if allah mab had been historically but
certainly I hear any number of doctors
say if I see a patient with
significant tumor burden with rapidly
growing disease then then I'm going to
put them on targeted therapy first
because they don't have time for
immunotherapy to kick in and we did
knock down that tumor burden a little
bit a lot of variation in the field
unfortunately we just have to wait for
the data I mean it's a great problem to
have right that to finally have some
options like this but but uh no clarity
at this point thank you so so all of
those newly approved drugs that you
mentioned in one of your earlier slide
it seems that you know those are very
promising why are some doctors still
prescribing chemo or are they still
prescribing chemo I know that in 2013
about a quarter of patients with
metastatic melanoma we're still treated
with chemo versus the newer drugs and my
sense is that's beginning to change a
little bit but we still have a way to go
unfortunately I think we still have a
way to go and I think it goes back to
the fact that some doctors see very few
melanoma patients maybe just a couple of
years and so if you're doing your CMI's
and you're trying to stay current with
everything you're going to do your CMI's
and breast cancer lung cancer colorectal
cancer and spending a couple of days or
a long weekend to get up to speed on the
current melanoma drugs probably not a
good use of your time if you only have
two or three patients and so I think you
know that speaks too windy or for
patients out or some things like that
but but certainly nope no melanoma
patient should be treated with
chemotherapy as first-line therapy in
today's environment and and so two
things around that number one if you
don't feel comfortable prescribing some
drug other than chemotherapy then refer
your patient to somebody who can do that
but number two what we're seeing now is
the immunotherapy drugs in particularly
the anti pd-1 drugs are showing good
efficacy and other tumor types that are
far more common and I think that what
we'll see is the oncology field in
general become more and more comfortable
with immunotherapy drugs because they're
using
long and some of the other areas and so
when they do see a melanoma patient
they'll say okay pd-1 works in melanoma
as well I've been using it along with a
number of patients so I know how to deal
with this I think we're going to be
seeing that close to close the gap over
the next year or two right and and the
last question that we have is there's a
lack of side effects mean that the
treatment isn't working i mean we spoke
about reporting side effects to the
treatment team but what if a patient
isn't having any side effects is that a
cause for concern for the patient or or
is it not or does it mean that that
treatment might not be working what does
that mean I think right now it doesn't
mean a whole lot we certainly know that
in some cancers and some therapies the
the worse the side effects the more
impact it's having on on the on the
cancer that doesn't seem to be as true
and the melanoma drugs that we're seeing
now and in fact almost the opposite can
sometimes happen there's that there's a
great story about about the development
of aluminum at that the one of the early
people on the on the drug and the
clinical trials came in for scans and
the scan showed that the tumor said were
larger on the scans and they had been in
the baseline scan and and the the doctor
was sat down with the patient and said
so how are you feeling before giving the
scan results you know how are you
feeling the patient said yeah I feel
good I feel better than I have in a
while I feel I feel like the drugs
working you know because I'm not having
the same issues i was having before and
and very much the credit of this
particular physician he said huh maybe i
should pay attention to that and and
what we now know is that if it luma mad
can cause an inflammatory response in
the tumor site which makes the tumors
look larger on the scan even though they
actually are responding to the drug this
patient felt good the doctor said well
if they feel better maybe something is
happening that I'm
sing on the scans let's let go a little
bit longer and of course at the next
round of scans the tumors have shrunk so
sometimes people do fine on the on the
immunotherapy drugs and and and the
targeted therapy drugs and don't feel
those side effects from there and they
actually are working there seems not to
be that connection right now very
helpful thank you well that concludes
our question-and-answer session can do
you have any final comments before we
conclude well I feel like everybody's
probably tired of hearing me talk by now
but I would just say you know I
appreciate everything that people are
doing and learning about this area of
melanoma and and again with the
landscape changing so quickly staying
and good communication with your patient
making sure that they are well supported
and that they are well informed actually
creates a synergy between the healthcare
treatment team and the patient that will
absolutely result in better outcomes and
and and not only will result in better
outcomes it's the right thing to do it's
respectful of the people who have
submitted themselves to your care and I
appreciate your interest in and pursuing
this further great thank you soon as a
reminder this will be available for six
months on demand so please be sure to
share this information with your
colleagues if you think it would be
helpful for them and and again don't
hesitate to reach out to the melanoma
Research Foundation if we can be of any
assistance to you or your practice thank
you